so imagine like you're standing in the
middle
and on both sides of you is a timeline
of your past
and then a timeline of your future and
so
imagine now that as you have these this
timeline of the past
if you're thinking about the past it
can't help but then
become your future i believe that each
and every one of us has the power within
ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
so this is my first attempt here at a
solo episode
and you know i've been thinking a lot
about
it's funny i didn't put this on the list
so so i want to go through my
20 lessons of 2020. this is me being
vulnerable and it's
that's actually a word i've been
thinking about a lot this year
is the difference between transparency
and vulnerability
and i think that we all have different
ranges for that so um
i would call myself someone that has a
large amount of transparency
like there's a lot about myself and what
i'm willing to share that i'm very
comfortable with i just
don't care and then there's like it
takes
to pretty far along the line until i get
to the vulnerable spot where i'm like
yeah i'm not i'm not ready to talk about
that so to me this
this is actually me being vulnerable
because i it's not
something very planned out um and you
know let's face it lessons are never
easy so
uh and with my ability to go on and on
we'll just see what comes out so um
okay so let's have at it so these are in
no particular order
um i was trying to i was
i was trying to um number them in an
order but
it's hard and one kind of flows into the
neck sometimes so i'm just gonna
i just drew a line through halfway and
we're just gonna do the first ten
so um twenty through eleven
uh lesson number twenty uh so
intuition is real this is a lesson this
year that i've learned
um as you know
i mean we all have those feelings right
we have those intuitions we have those
feelings about something and we're
worried
about it and here's the thing i feel
like we tend to
um go into the ones that feel good
and follow them and run with them but
the ones that feel
bad or concerning or that you
kind of don't want to admit we tend to i
tend to use my mind and go um that's not
real or like
that's the worst thing i could tell
myself that's probably not true
and then you know through life we
find out that these things are at times
and so
uh i know this is something that we've
all heard so many times but
it probably can't be reiterated enough
is that i do believe we have an inner
compass we have like an inner
lie detector system our soul knows the
answer
our higher self is trying to communicate
with us um
and it's it's really about getting good
at hearing the no's
and the concerns and the red flags
uh as much as you're getting those
intuitions about like oh i think i
should take this job i should move to
that house
i should do this or that like those are
those are easy it's the ones that you
don't want to hear
that you need to listen to as well and
so for me this year it's
it's been learning that and learning it
through
difficult things that um
you just have to admit and you know
it's a shortcut right just take that
take the information
and you know it's on the other end of it
if somebody is uh
willing to be receptive to it and
participate in the
in the confrontation or in the change or
whatever it may be
uh then it's uh you know you've got the
right people around you
because the people that want you to stay
the same
are in a relationship with that old self
and that old dynamic so don't let that
be your guide
okay number 19 no one holds the keys to
your life
so this came through uh you know
having heartbreak and going home and
back to indiana for a few months this
summer and
i i was realizing some patterns
in my life and in relationships and so i
was looking
for i was looking for my parents to help
sort of
clarify those and like help fix those
and apologize or
you know explain something and you know
that was somehow going to
resolve these issues and that i needed
participation from someone
to um alchemize the situation
and to heal it and you know my therapist
said
one day on our call she said
at the end of it no one holds any keys
for you
and i was like oh and i kind of started
crying and i was like wow that's um
you know that's a big responsibility and
she said it is but you don't have to do
it alone like you have people that
are here i'm here for you you know there
are people here for you but
you getting to a better place with
situations like
no one is going to just
you know open that door or close another
it's going to come from you
and that no one holds the keys and i was
like wow and so
a lot of this year has been about
responsibility accountability
accountability for myself
and how i feel and so
that was one of them really really a big
one that day was like
no one holds any keys for you i'm like
oh why not
um okay number 18
uh i won't starve to death if i don't
eat
isn't that funny that i have to like
have that
even write that down um those who know
me know i'm like
super into food and i always have to
have food around and
um early early this year um
and probably uh it was uh february
i had just gotten back to california and
like it was like okay let's let's do a
little fast and
so i decided to do one day which turned
into 36 hours because you know you've
got the night before in the morning and
like the nights between the day so i
called it 36 hours
of just water and what i realized was
that
that my hunger would go in waves like it
would um
every like every few hours i'd have a 45
minute
hunger spike and after 45 minutes it
would just go away
and i was like wow huh that's
interesting
and then also knowing like sort of
debunking the ideas
about like you know you'll slow your
metabolism down if you don't eat
at the end of the day my good friend
jordan saya would say it i interviewed
him for my podcast
it's just calories in versus calories
out these things
are not true and that um
and and no one no one didn't lose weight
because they didn't eat
frequently enough right so it's just
it's just a math problem
calorie deficit always wins if you want
to lose weight but anyway
um the big point about this is i won't
start a death if i don't eat and so it
doesn't actually get worse you just have
to ride
that really punishing wave
okay number 17 how to allow help is
actually
you loving yourself and saying you're
worthy of love so something i think that
especially for
women um because we tend to be you know
fixers
and uh don't ask for help
um but i think people in general i mean
guys don't like to ask for directions
right so i guess we all have our thing
um so but i found myself this
this summer being in such a position of
sadness
that i had to have people help me i had
to have
people hold me up i had to
i had to allow people to take care of me
and to help
raise my energy um
and exhaust them and i knew i was but it
was
it was necessary and uh i couldn't do it
on my own and so
um and let's face it
think about when someone asks you for
help
and this is just like flipping the
dynamic it makes you feel really good
like when someone says i can you help me
with this
a lot of times you're like sure and it's
an honor and
you know it's a form of respect and so
uh
really also what it comes down to too is
you believing that you're worthy of that
you're worthy of someone helping you
you're worthy of someone sacrificing
for you um and so i
had to do a lot of that this year and um
it really showed me how um how much
people loved me even if i didn't do
anything and even if i was draining on
them
like there's a season for everything and
that
you don't always have to be in a state
of giving to keep a relationship going
you can receive too and so um
it was kind of me saying that i'm worthy
of this
uh sacrifice from someone
number 16 how to be the observer this is
a little bit more of a complicated
concept
but the observer is
essentially being able to look past
people's projections
and see the true self so
what made me realize it was um
i was in this i went home like i said
to indiana and i lived with my parents
for three months and
when i was there i was getting pulled
into these old dynamics and this is what
happens right when we're with our family
we kind of get pulled into these old
patterns and dynamics and so
um you know i remember there was
something
where i made a comment and then my mom
went and told my dad about it afterwards
and
they kind of it was like felt like i was
getting ganged up on
and i was like oh my gosh and then
something happened with my mom and my
dad came to her defense and was like i
think what your mom is trying to say and
i
realized like i still i i was getting
pulled into these dynamics and like
quipping back and getting defensive a
little bit and
and and i it just didn't feel good
either and so
as i'm shifting i'm sort of recognizing
in these two instances because again i'm
immersed in it because i'm home
um i'm recognizing this like incredible
like highly operating and functioning
codependency system where they protect
each other and
and that's fine it totally works um
and but i realized of my participation
in it and how
um i didn't need to it was their dynamic
and it was there
it was it wasn't about me it was about
them and it was
um i didn't need to get pulled into the
energetics of it
and to that old sort of defensiveness or
protecting myself or justifying
and so being the observer is essentially
being able to look
above the situation uh and being able to
see
the dynamic playing out that has
everything to do with them
and nothing to do with you
that's just their way of operating and
so
through that experience i was then able
to do a much better job
the rest of the time i'm able to be in
the space a lot more when i see someone
get triggered or project or shoot even
if i get triggered and i'm starting to
see
how this we are not our wounds
essentially is the end of it when
someone has a reaction they're being
triggered into their wounds and the they
are not their wounds they
at a soul level are whole and wonderful
and beautiful and
love and everybody at the core wants the
same thing right everybody wants to be
um happy and joyful and
um and so anything outside of that
is not them it is a wound it is a
trigger
um and it is something that happened to
them at some point in their life where
they're affected
so basically you have an instance happen
um that you then get a feeling from so
say there's some big trauma say you got
yelled at a lot as a kid and so then
you create this feeling and your body as
a response
to say oh my god that didn't feel good
i'm i'm ner like maybe you're a kid and
you're
anxious and you're scared and so
anytime someone starts yelling you go
back
into that moment it's like a it's like
an it's like
it marks that point in time and and so
every event draws you back to that
emotional moment and you get triggered
and that's why people act like kids
sometimes that's why they act immature
that's why they
run away they they have they can't talk
they
um or they yell right so you learn
you're patterning from like how you
what happened in that moment and so um
so i just learned how to be the observer
of situations and
to see people's um protective layer
as nothing that has to do with me it's
not personal almost everything that
happens in life is
really not about you
however everybody is giving you an
indication of yourself
that's for another idea number 15
i learned how to feel my feelings so a
practice that was given to me earlier
this year was to
stop sporadically through the day
i was actually told me do do it every
hour and like put your hand on your body
and just kind of close your eyes and
feel like what are you actually feeling
is it tightness is it
um is it anxiety is it uh
sadness is it like what are you feeling
and um and so i learned to you know i
started doing that
and then you know it's pretty much been
water work
since then so i actually had to choose
my word after
the summer i was like i'm not i think
i'm moving on from the word feel and i'm
moving into
feel joy so
i had to re-clarify to the universe what
i wanted
um but feelings are so
important and they really are um
they're an elevated awareness to
situations and so some people are better
at it than others
but i was not that great at feeling my
feelings
and slowing it really
involves slowing down and i've done
everything in my life
so fast and so um i don't even like it
when somebody takes a while to answer
like do you want water and they
think about it i'm like just i don't
know say the first word that comes to
mind
um so just slowing down and allowing
that
pause that gives you
more perspective to the situation
um so feel your feelings 14
number 14 investing in friends i had
this great conversation
with um some friends uh on a hike
and it was about lessons that had been
learned in life
and one of them was just the value of
investing into friends
and so that kind of stuck with me
and i'd say that this year especially
with everything
that that went on and uh and leaning on
people
there was um just a lot of checking in a
lot of phone calls and
and so i recognized just how much was
given to me and so
you know there's a season for everything
and so everyone so some people have
needed that
needed that reciprocal love and
attention
that maybe in the past i wasn't as good
at making space for so it actually plays
into feeling the feelings
and feeling for people but but investing
into friends
investing into these relationships that
are investing into you and
um you know i would say that i used to i
have a lot of friends but i maybe didn't
and like i tend to have a lot of deep
friendships but
or i have a few deep friendships and i
don't really nurture the rest of them as
much but i
i would say this year i've done a much
better job of of
really checking in and and asking how
other people are doing
um a lot more and so and what comes back
is just more love when you show love you
get the love
and so uh investing into friends making
time sometimes it's a sacrifice
right but guess what sometimes it's a
sacrifice what they've done for you too
if you're you know calling bitching
about something happening in your life
they might be busy but they but they're
making
that time and so it's about it's about
making time for them too
and um and what you water grows so um i
feel like i've had a lot of friendships
that have really really grown
and um and deepened even more
so so investing into friends
number 13 uh meditation is medication
so i use the analogy of a roller coaster
for meditation and that it's like you're
at the bottom
and you're clicking up to go to the top
of the top of the first drop
and by the end of the day you get pretty
close
but the meditation element to life kind
of resets
your roller coaster and so if you don't
do it enough then you know
inevitably you kind of come out the
other side of it and you you know you're
on the downslide
and then you're just hanging on for dear
life and you're on an emotional roller
coaster you're just kind of like
you don't even you don't have a it's not
you need a reset
and you're instead you're on this ride
just holding on for dear life
instead of controlling it instead of
having patience and being able to pause
there's no pause when you're
you know flipping upside down on a ride
right so
um you know meditation has been
something that i've finally done on a
regular basis
for probably i started in
maybe june um late june i finally
started so
it's been a really beautiful time
sometimes i have all kinds of different
rituals in it i'll pull cards i'll
burn certain things i'll have certain
oils
i will meditate i will do breathing app
breathing exercises
i will do soul dialoguing either in
in my head or on paper and journal
sometimes i journal so again it's about
kind of a dedicated space and practice
to
um you know
resetting getting things out
and um clearing your mind it's kind of
it's just
it's an emotional reset um so i
i think uh you know there's even some
science behind
the chemicals when you do enough of this
it's like natural
volume so um if that is something of
interest to people maybe start
meditating um
okay number 12
boundaries and what the hell they are
okay
so i didn't have i mean i always thought
that boundaries were something that
was for other people to you
and instead what i've learned is that
boundaries are
for yourself in relationship to others
so it's not about don't cheat on me it's
not about don't lie to me it's not about
don't
steal from me it's about your own
boundaries that help you
navigate relationships and which ones
you should be in and not
in and what you're willing to put up
with and what you're
not so there also is a layer of needing
enough self-worth to create them
you need to believe that you're worth
those boundaries
more you are worth more you are the most
valuable
element in the situation and if you
you have to honor yourself enough to
stick with those boundaries
um and in response what happens is that
you get people that honor those
you they you get it in this the same in
return if you don't have boundaries then
they're not going to
there's nothing to follow there's no
they don't
they don't treat you the way that you
want to be treated um so
boundaries boundaries are just they're
just something i just never
had and so um i realized that
i needed to be alone to learn them i
needed to
understand what i was worth what i was
willing to put up with
and just what i how i wanted to feel
and getting control of your own energy
and how you
feel without interference um
to know where like um home bases
how many people out there don't really
know what their home base is
how they want to how they feel
emotionally when there's nothing
pulling nothing pushing nothing
nothing poking
um i think that's really hard and i can
i can absolutely understand how hard it
is
life gets to you family friends uh
children
i mean these some of these i have some
of them i don't um but
uh but life keeps happening and so like
understanding
who you are uh at your core without
anything else has been super important
for me so
yeah and just that element of like
boundaries being
something that i have for other people
versus i have four
other people like something that they
need to not do it's something that i
need to not do
i need to know when to walk away from a
situation because
it's not me staying in integrity to
myself
and what i feel like i deserve
okay uh number eleven um
this is honestly number one overall but
based on just drawing a line here and
reading these off
um and so of course i reversed my top
ten because i was like well let's at
least make this the last one i do but
this has been the biggest one
so i the pattern that i was trying to
uh understand was being in relationships
where i wasn't chosen
and you know that had happened in the
last two
and i was like okay i i don't need a
third to create an
actual a pattern here i've done this
with this has happened twice
someone doesn't choose me what is the
problem
i am a common denominator and
so what i hadn't
what i realized was that the lesson
was that i was supposed to choose myself
so the lesson in wanting someone to
choose me is that i was supposed to be
choosing myself
um
[Music]
i'm a fixer and i came home and i was
like
you know i ended up learning that um
you know i didn't remember a lot from my
childhood like i don't know why but
you know my first 10 years i don't
remember a ton and then
and so one thing i learned about that
was that
i um dad worked a lot and so he was gone
during the week and just on the weekends
he'd be home and
a kid doesn't know that this is all for
the right reasons they just
don't know consistency and so it creates
an abandonment wound
where they're afraid of being abandoned
and so
you know you're not you're not you're a
kid you don't know what's going on
so uh that began which is an anxious
attachment
style because you're afraid of being
abandoned so you're anxious that
someone's gonna
leave and then when i started
remembering things was when i was
about 10 and that's when i started
racing and so
we go to the racetrack and you know i
love my father and i've probably got
honestly he's responsible for so many
wonderful
aspects of me but um he would yell at me
and
i found out pretty much every weekend
and uh and so then
i said to mom what do we do to fix that
and she said we gave in
and i was like oh
and it was like i realized then
i'm a fixer because that like how did we
how did i
keep my dad around because i was afraid
that he was going to leave because i was
afraid of being abandoned
i fixed things so now in every
relationship
i go i don't want them to leave so i fix
things
and you lose yourself you lose your uh
you lose your
um sense of self you lose your sort of
autonomy as a as a person um
and um there are no boundaries then
so in that i realized the dynamics that
made me
not choose myself and so
all of that effort that i put in to
someone else
i now realized was meant for me
and so honestly that is the greatest
lesson
of of 2020 for me is that uh
and this is why everyone out everyone is
showing you
something about yourself when i wasn't
chosen
the message is you're not choosing
yourself
it's like you know i mean we're going to
get into some of the other things that
get
you know that get into aspects of this
concept
a little deeper but um but everything is
as a mirror for us and that's a
complicated concept
um but maybe by the end of these 20
things there'll be a bit more of an
understanding for some of what that is
but
um something that i wanted
i was i needed to give to myself because
again going back to one of these other
ones
no one holds the keys like no one holds
the keys for these
for for this yearning that you have so
um you have to give it to yourself so
okay
so that's 20 through 11 and
we'll be back next week for 10 through 1
of the top 20 lessons of 2020.
we're back for uh the second part of
my top 20 lessons
of 2020 probably could be a hundred
deep but i came up with the top 20. uh
last week was um number 20 down to 11
and this week we're going to
go 10 down to 1. and the thing is those
the i wanted i was trying to put them in
order
but honestly it's very difficult there's
there they have their significance
they climb to the top at different
points in time of when you need them so
i don't know they're out of order
they're in there they're no particular
no particular order at all um
but they are all significant lessons so
let's get into it
okay number 10 uh
the power of cold water i interviewed
wim hof this year
and um you know one thing that i have
realized well that i got maybe
maybe it's a little more conscious now
is that
uh you know i it's i'm
fairly brave but there are some things
that are
issues like as blocks or things i don't
go towards and one of them is sure as
hell
cold water so
so i thought you know what this is
probably something i should lean into
um and uh he says a shower a cold shower
day keeps the doctor away
so i mean especially in 2020 isn't that
something we all want to do
um so i've started taking cold showers
ever since i interviewed him and my pool
at the house is really really cold so
um in the in the in the non-summer time
in arizona it's it's
down into the 50s and so i've been using
that as my cold plunge
but i i guess there's two parts of it
one is the sort of
um the sort of internal benefits that it
creates that are
like not seen essentially if it you know
ups your um um
you know resilience to uh um
viruses and things like that but mood
and skin and
all kinds of various other things but
the other one is just just leaning into
the difficulty
and expanding my own comfort zone of
being uncomfortable
which is kind of the name of the game
for me so anyway cold water
it's been something that i have realized
i can do now
so hell yeah me uh number nine
i didn't realize how easygoing i was
until i was single
um you know i've always been a really go
with the flow person but i also am
strong
so i guess what i've realized is that
maybe my uh like triggers got in the way
and things like that that would make me
feel like i had like kind of put me or
more on edge um and maybe created some
resistance or um
you know less easy breezy flowiness even
though i'm always up for anything maybe
my mood wasn't exactly
there but i i
am i am friggin easy breezy like i'm up
for
anything and i just don't have any more
bad days anymore
and i'm super grateful to recognize that
in myself because as i've
been in relationships for 16 years
straight pretty much
i kind of didn't know where i was and
all that am i easy going am i not am i
too uptight am i too controlling
um am i too opinionated am i too easy
going
do i not stand up for myself enough like
where did i fall and all that so i feel
like it's it's shown me me
um okay number eight i also didn't know
how good at being alone i was until i
was alone
this goes towards um this goes this is
maybe not necessarily like a super
fundamental lesson as much as it sort of
taught me about myself so it has been
you know it's not like get in the cold
water and that could apply to anyone but
this is a lesson i've learned in myself
and that
a lesson in confidence and um
to not fear the unknown and again like i
just said i
hadn't been alone in 16 years so and
know how to do it
and what i realized is that i'm really
really good at it and
it's not a problem and it's very
comfortable and i'm like oh man
i kind of like my space now so
i'm sure that uh you know in the future
that could change but
um but for now i just i've realized how
good at being alone i am
and it's always a space that even
when i was living in north carolina i
described that as a time where i really
learned a lot about myself too because i
i spent a lot of time alone there i did
have some
space there for sure and especially
spaces in land so
um but i i realized in sort of the quiet
days um not moments but days uh
what what do i want to do if i could do
anything and it's in those
spaces where you start to learn and
figure out what it is that you actually
want to do
there's so much of the time that we end
up conforming and
[ __ ] shape-shifting and compromising
and giving up our self to appease others
and um i i mean it's i get it it's hard
because you know i also find joy in
making someone else happy so
it's a fine line um but it's in being
alone that
you really learn who you are and
i'm grateful for that number seven
the memories of of the past keep us
hooked into repeating the same thing in
the future
so this is sort of like a reframing of
karma
and um it's that
imagine because i'm pretty visual so
imagine like you're standing
in the middle and on both sides of you
is a timeline of your past
and then a timeline of your future and
so
imagine now that as you have these this
timeline of the past
if you're thinking about the past it
can't help but then
become your future you're not thinking
about anything else
and so it is in
letting go and sort of
allowing yourself to think greater than
those memories or think
different than those memories about what
it is that you want
um that you can then create the new
future otherwise
as you think about the past you create
them in the future and then what are you
on
a karmic wheel i was like oh man that
was just such a
a good clarifying visual of how
we keep creating our future by thinking
thoughts of the past
got to get beyond yourself as my friend
joe dispenza would say
okay number six this one's
tough everyone is reflecting back to you
who you are
and what needs healing
i mean this is a big concept
it's a concept of mirroring and um
but you know
[Music]
as we sort of walk through life and
um we get uh triggered
that trigger is just showing us
something that's unhealed in our self
but it's
being shown to us through that person um
so like for instance i would say that
something i judge in people
is that the um is that uh like if
they're lazy let's say
but it's because and so i'm gonna pull
in number five because number five
actually in this list is what we judge
is what we deny in ourselves
so in this reflection and this sort of
understanding of the judgment then that
comes
in because we're triggered uh what it's
really showing us
is something that we deny in ourselves
and that um
you know for me in that specific example
let's say of being
judging someone that's lazy it's because
i deny myself the ability to be lazy
so if someone is being lazy i'm
triggered
because it's an aspect of myself that i
deny
and that needs healing and needs
balancing so
yeah looking at the people in your life
especially the closest ones to you and
especially in relationships
you know what is it that's triggering
you and and
and and looking at that trigger as a
teacher
and that's really the truth because as
we've healed that aspect let's say now
let's fast forward to a place where i
now have a really healthy balance with
resting
and um uh
being what i would maybe label as lazy
but let's just call it resting
and recovering and
healing and you know
you know whatever resting then if i
do that with myself now if somebody else
is doing that
i can see the aspect that they may need
that that might be exactly what they
need right now
and now i'm healed and i'm not triggered
by it so you can see how if somebody
does something that you judge there's
work to be done
that's been a really helpful teacher for
me
because it is hard right you're you're
just you you you don't
it's hard to really see yourself so
that's why the world shows up as a
mirror to show us our self
so we know where to look where where are
the weaknesses where are the wounds
and then we can go to work on them
because we we
as an eye don't it's hard to see those
things within ourselves so
it's the people that that produ that
provide the mirror
so lovingly of course number
four on the top 20 countdown of lessons
is the body holds emotions and trauma
uh and the mind is part of that puzzle
so
so the body holds emotions and trauma
i started doing some well i've actually
you know always had massages but i
started getting into sort of a new
aspect of bodywork she was working on my
back
and she was she was she was get going
after the spot and it just wasn't going
away
and she said to me if this spot
had a sound what would it be
give the spot a sound and i was like hmm
okay
i don't know what that means but i was
like all right so you kind of lay in
there
and as she's you know working i'm like i
let let out like this
and it just sounds it's so uncomfortable
right it's such an odd thing
and so i kind of let it out and it
wasn't really maybe authentic
um and then um then the next time i did
was much more
like it was like i couldn't control it
it just kind of came out
and much more more of it and after i did
that
i started crying i started bawling and i
was like wow
that was the craziest thing to have
sort of this um frequency essentially
the sound
activate this wound in me and
um this emotional the stuck energy
and so i've since then gone
time more times and it happens again and
again i'm not it doesn't
i don't go in with the expectation of it
um in fact the last time i didn't cry
but i definitely had a lot of
information come
through through different s in different
parts of the body
but understanding this idea that when we
have an experience um
that is strong enough to create an
emotion a feeling
that if you don't get rid of that
through
saying it um processing it
um therapy or talking to the person or
whoever whatever the moment was and you
just keep it inside
that it's stuck and it's stuck as in
like i
imagine and again i'm not a doctor i
don't know i just kind of use my
imagination for how to process the crap
in my life but
i can't imagine it as being like balls
of energy that are just
stuck in my body and um the the sound
is like the door to the emotion
and i also experience this with another
um another practice that i have which is
this
um this this this class called the class
and it's with taran toomey and she
started doing this a long long time ago
in new york and
you know obviously with everything going
on um you know they have a digital
platform and an
app now so it's easy so i just put it on
my computer and do it
um but these are you know 45 minutes to
an hour long and
it's moving around to music like you
have a repetitious move
and um and then there's some sort of
verbal prompting
and and and and and then you're also
getting audible
so you're sort of making sounds and i
really feel like this is the
the the sound the vibration the
frequency like
opens up these wounds it's like a door
and all of a sudden
out flooding comes the emotion and so i
think that maybe some people can
identify with the idea that you know
when you say things out loud
that there is a charge to them it's like
you know if you have an issue with
somebody your voice starts to shake when
you tell them
or something that you're scared of and
you tell someone
that you love and all of a sudden you
start crying and you can't or you can't
hold it back
or you're trying to um there's more
there
and it's like i think that it's so
important that we
start to all including myself which has
been such a process this year but i'm
feeling much better about it all in fact
like a good cry now
but get more in touch with those
feelings and those process the
processing of it and and
letting yourself get emotional um
dare i say i actually like having a good
cry now
it feels good it feels clearing
um and uh you know i also think it's
just an expansion on this concept and
idea
is that here in 2020 we're just in this
we're just in we're just in an era where
you know especially for men it's
you know it's being asked to to show up
in that way it's being asked to to feel
your feelings and to get in touch with
them and to balance out
you know your masculine and feminine
side as well as for women and they're
masculine and feminine but i think that
in emotions and feeling is being called
right now
and feeling into your body and um
and i and i and i know it it's it's um
it's not comfortable but i will say that
in
in in doing it you find comfort in the
discomfort
it's um it becomes more familiar
it's like an old it's like a it's a it's
a teacher
it's a friend it's a teacher um but i
think that we
that's what's being asked of us this
year but especially for men
to feel those feelings communicate
cry um okay
number three on the list
everyone has childhood trauma boom
i said it it's true i had a great
childhood
i love my parents they're wonderful
human beings
um and
it doesn't mean though that there aren't
things that happened
that i didn't need to deal with later on
it's like
simple it's quite simply this you know
you're to love them
you're going to love your kids too much
or too little one of the other right
i mean there's just it's hard you can't
nail that you can't nail it
and um you know you can definitely give
them tools though
i think that's part that's definitely
something you can do but
but but basically i feel like this whole
idea that everyone is childhood trauma
i think that maybe trauma is the word
that needs to be
um sort of
understood in a much more uh
acceptable way like i remember when i
went home for the summer
that when i said the word trauma
it's it triggers like it sounds horrible
it's like
you know your arm didn't get cut off did
it you know you didn't you know
these horrible things didn't happen
you're still you got you know 10 fingers
10 toes you're well you know
it's like trauma is not like a car
accident trauma just means that
something happened in your reality that
was big enough for you
to create an emotion as a result it
didn't just
it didn't just sort of come in your mind
and out it didn't just sort of have a
flow
in and out it sat it sat in you it it
sunk in it took root
and um and that's a trauma
um so uh it's it they're
they're we all have them wounds whatever
you want to call them
and the quicker that we admit that
there's
there's unpacking that can and should
need to be done
with um the patterning of you know how
we were raised
and that's just it is it's like do you
love your patterns that's what i was
asking the question of it's like
do i like this pattern and if i don't
how do i fix it and it's in the
it's in that exploration of
the root cause of the pattern which is
almost
always going to lead you back to
childhood that you can find it
so true healing comes from pulling it
out by the root not by band-aiding it
not by
you know showing up at your therapist as
a couple and going like okay well tell
her how you feel and tell him you know
it's like
that's a band-aid right get out of there
you get you go see your own person
you go see your own person and everybody
like let's get you get down to it for
yourself
heal yourself to heal your relationships
all of them um
again to as you know pulling other
aspects of what i've learned in
to pull back in those aspects of like
what am i judging
what triggers me um to heal yourself so
that you're not
you're not in that space anymore you
have more good days
okay number two
okay number two number one or again
they're not in particular order but i
but i'm i am saving sort of bigger
concepts for the very end here
as i did in the last episode um so bear
with me
there's a there's an idea that if you if
you can't explain
something simply you don't understand it
well enough so i'm just going gonna go
ahead and say that
these are new these are concepts that
i could probably work on for the rest of
my life um
so i'm gonna try and try and do the best
i can to explain and explore
these ideas that might um might be
meaningful
to you or might make you just get to
thinking
and and what your relationship is with
them
but okay number two uh duality is part
of the whole
okay so it's this idea
like if someone were to ask me what i
thought that we
are here to as humans experience
i would say that that is to experience
duality
but the
goal or the idea is to end up
being able to um
have oneness which is more towards you
know enlightenment
um when you're when you are connected
wholly to everything oneness
so in my year um
as for many it's been a lot has happened
and it's created an expansion of my own
experiences
um so it's like as if
i'm inside of this bubble inside of this
circle but i'm
i'm isolated to the middle like i i i'm
not i haven't
i haven't experienced enough uh outside
of my little area
to recognize that they're all inside the
bubble as in the hole
so this year i've had more expanding
experiences into
deep deep sadness and sadness and
you know broken-heartedness and
confusion and
lack of self-worth and um
lack of purpose and all kinds of you
know
really really hard aspects but then on
the other hand
what's been beautiful is is is
experiencing
joy at a sporadic moment doing next to
nothing
just sort of being and whether it's like
being in nature or being in my house or
being with myself or just like i don't
know it's like a wave that comes over me
i'm just like feeling this
joy of like it's hard to put it into
words
um but just feeling perfect in the
moment
and um and so i've experienced this sort
of
more the the the center of this bubble
is expanding and growing and i'm getting
towards those edges more
closer and closer and closer and in it
recognizing
that um all these other people that i
might not have been able to relate to
in certain emotions or experiences now
i have now experienced them so again
it's
showing me that in this duality it's
part of the whole like
you know and that that we're all part of
that same thing
you know as i've experienced more
aspects it's allowed me to relate to
more people which means that
you know we're not that different and so
um
it's in this duality that i exist in
both
right i exist in grief and i inexist in
joy
and it's all part of the whole like it's
all there
it's it's one end of the spectrum
it's just you know it's about finding
sort of the balance of where you want to
be in the middle of it it's why you know
like
you know people go to extremes it's it's
um
it's just touching touching the touching
the edges of this
and um and uh and finding yourself and
that
you're all of it you're right like i
know i'm rambling on but again like i
said bear with me because
these are concepts that are kind of new
to me but the simplistic
words of it is just that within duality
you exist on both ends of the spectrum
and so that
is helping me understand oneness by
expanding my experiences
okay now we're going to land at number
one
on my top 20 lessons of 2020.
so this is even more complicated to
explain but
maybe i can be be concise
so it's the idea that we're all
divine we are all god and
before i lose anybody too much let's get
talking
because it's triggering i think this
idea especially when it comes to
religion is
like it's blasphemous or um
uncomfortable
and i'd ask what is the discomfort in
that is the discomfort that
now you recognize your power
that you recognize um
what you could be um
[Music]
and so the thing that's got me to
understand this or think this is the
idea that and i listen to a lot of
abraham hicks i don't know if anybody
else does but
if you don't i love listening to abraham
hicks she is um her real name is esther
hicks but abraham is who she channels so
it's channeled information
um but there's a lot of talk about um
feeling good
and sort of you know if something
doesn't feel good then
you know that's it's out of resonance
it's not it's not
on your frequency it's not meant for you
and so
um if we're to sort of use that
as as an indicator
god is love i feel like that's something
that most everyone can agree on and if
god is love
love is always love is whole and happy
and pure
and joyful and it's all those
really good feelings so now
if you experience something you know
anger mad triggers whatever
it doesn't feel good right why doesn't
it feel good
it's because it's really not you at your
core
it's just like when you look at someone
and
um like your kids maybe you know and you
just see them past
all of their issues you see them past
their you know hating you
i hate you mom um or you know
not wanting to be around you or whatever
it is or something that they do or say
and you just still love them because you
know you see them for who they you see
their essence their true self you you
can sort of
feel the divinity within them and
anything
else is just not really them it's an
adolescence it's
uh it's uh you know growing pains it's
whatever but it's not really them it's
part of the learning experience
and so like this just sort of
extrapolate that out to every
everything it said if it's not
if it doesn't make you feel good if it
makes you uncomfortable if it makes you
feel shameful if it makes you feel angry
regretful any of those kinds of things
it's really not you at your core
and so for me that's what i've i've
sort of been exploring into is like
man how can i love someone better
it's like i have this example this this
story um
about being in my neighborhood and um
out walking my dogs
and uh this guy was mad about my dogs
being off their leash and
he's like hey they should be on a leash
and i don't really like to put them on
leashes
even though they have an electric collar
i was like hey i have them on an
electric collar if that makes you feel
better
and um then another day i was walking
and
as i'm sort of wrapping around back to
the house and
they're off the leashes and i can see
him looking at me
and i sort of energetically give this
whole like what are you looking at like
they're fine and he's looking at me with
this energy of
of like your dogs are off leashes and
i'm watching you
and so i get back to the house and the
next day my house manager shows up and
she goes so
i got a call from the homeowners and i
said dogs off leech and she goes yeah
and i was like i know i know i know who
it was
so anyway uh within probably a week of
that
i went out for oh i was out
running with my dog and doing some short
interval running things and i wasn't
going very far but
he was out there was a guy outside
walking and i thought
you know um i'll run on this side of the
street and then we'd go by and turn
around and
and i was like hmm could this be the guy
down the street or not i had that
feeling and then i was like i don't know
he seemed like he wasn't very happy he
probably is not out for a nature walk
then
and um so i i went by and i turned
around because i was just running like a
400 meter run
and i turned around and i could see he
was right behind me now
and he has phone out as if he was sort
of like held it up
sort of like as if he was taking a
picture and then put it back down
so i i turned around and i stopped and i
looked at him
but adding this interjecting this
information from when i heard that he
that there was a report to the
homeowners
to this moment i kept thinking to myself
you know what
don't fight this just don't fight this
how can i love this human better
if it is that important for him to have
the dogs on leash which seems
you know and and call the homeowners
like he has bigger issues and i don't
know what
they are but i'm going to just try and
see how i can love this human better
and so i'm like i'll put them on leashes
from now on and i'm going to smile at
them right
i'm just going to smile and say hi and
at least he can go well she seems pretty
nice i guess maybe i
overreacted i don't know so now
take me back going back to the moment
when the dog was when you know i turned
around and saw him
i stopped and i looked at him and i was
like hi my name is danica i was like
what's your name and he's like oh
so-and-so
and i said oh i said well where do you
live and he said oh i
live down the street and sure enough
it's the house and i was like
oh i was like you're the you're the guy
i'm like you're the one that was
uncomfortable with my dogs off the leash
i said um i i just want you to know that
whenever i go by now i put them on
leashes and it's true um
it's just that i wasn't going that far
because i was running a short distance
so i was turning around
um but when i go by i put them on
leashes i was like i just want you to
know
i have no problem with that it's okay
he's like oh you know it's just
you know what my um my uh my dogs
they're just yip
they bark a lot and um you know i love
dogs and
and i said yeah that's okay he's like
i'm so glad we're having this
conversation
and i said yeah it's it's not a problem
and um so anyway we said bye and carried
on
and um you know that picture as i think
he took a picture of me with my dog
not on a leash when i was running
nothing happened with it
and sure enough now it's like a wave
hello like oh
nice to see you and all i did was think
to myself how could i love this human
better and that's how
you know if we're going to pull religion
back in that's how kind of god sees
everything it sees everything
whole pure and love always forgiving and
in fact not even
needing to forgive because there's no
judgment and so how can we love each
other better
and it's like to see the divinity in
each of us and it's there
like how can i love this human better
how can i love it
from that space of
unconditional pure love how can i
how can i see the divinity and um
anyway it's given me a guidance system
to my own emotions and
and the things that that go on on a
day-to-day basis it's like
if it makes me uncomfortable it's just
not me it's not me at my core
and it's still something that i need to
work on and heal so
um totally a work in progress always
always working um but it's
been a really transformative 2020.
and um you know i i'm gonna share this
um
i had this revelation recently where i
have always been
you know i'm grateful for my experiences
yes um
but the one that i had most recently
which is more of an
a growth an evolution of that thought is
that
i also wouldn't change anything
i think that's a really for me that's a
that's a that's a that's a big place to
be because it's been really hard there's
been a lot of things that have been
challenging
and um but i wouldn't change anything
because it's led me to here
and um
and i'm grateful for that i'm grateful
for having
20 lessons of 2020 that i can share and
maybe maybe hopefully some of them hit
home
maybe some of them will plant a seed
maybe some of them
will be an expansion of something that
you've already been thinking about
and maybe you'll never listen to me
again i have no idea and it's okay
it's all okay it's all we're all
doing everything we can on the journey
and even when
we or someone else that we care about
is you know seemingly off it's all
leading to truth even in sort of those
derailing moments that
people have and those detours
the truth always comes out right the
truth about
how someone feels what you should be
doing
where you should be what's meant for you
it finds a way and uh there's definitely
one thing is that the universe is
persistent at you getting to a better
place
and it comes sort of knocking softly and
then it breaks down the door and then it
burns your house down
so you know say yes to the growth before
your house has to burn down but you know
what sometimes
it's just got to happen and that's like
extreme alchemy
and you know it's transformative and you
can never be the same person but in the
best way
so i hope that everyone can look at 2020
and find the gems
and um and sometimes it's you know it's
like a diamond it's through pressure
it's
it's made and so uh i i hope that their
people have um been able to turn into
diamonds this year
through the pressure and learn and grow
and expand
but the journey's never over
it's never done you can't get it you
can't get it wrong and it's never done
it's just a journey so here's to 2021
being um maybe a journey that has just a
little more joy in it
yeah and a little more freedom and a
little less masks
all right thanks guys for listening
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click
on the subscribe button